[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages time to see then what is making
the headlines with the columnist carol
malone
and the political editor of the
liverpool echo liam thorpe welcome to
both of you right
through till midnight we'll see them uh
so front pages let's start with the
metro
with many travelers facing uncertainty
over the government's traffic light
system the metro describes the situation
as hokicoki travel chaos
the eye reports that special bus
services will be laid on and social
media influencers
will be encouraged to use their
platforms to persuade 16
and 17 year olds to get the covert
vaccine to which they are now entitled
the daily mail accuses the climate
change minister alex sharma of hypocrisy
after it emerged he flew to 30 countries
on business
and never quarantined according to the
daily telegraph some universities are
setting their own
entrance exams because a level grades
affected by the pandemic
aren't giving them a clear enough
picture of who they should admit
same lead story on the front of the
guardian which suggests that extra cash
will be made available for medical
schools as grades surge
the prime minister is facing criticism
for laughing about margaret thatcher's
closure of coal mines
and saying it gave the uk a head start
to end the use of fossil fuels that's
the lead for the mirror
the ft has details of plans for what the
bank of england calls a modest
tightening of monetary policy in order
to keep
inflation under control wallpapers due
in obviously those are what we have so
far carol and liam are here
and let's start with the metro uh which
goes on sort of travel limbo
hokey cokey travel chaos um which
liam presumably grant shaps was hoping
it was a sort of headline that
that wasn't going to happen anymore
yeah absolutely you know he's hoping in
his announcement today as well to
provide a bit more
stability he's he's they've changed the
rules somewhat now that the
update for when uh um countries are
being put on certain
colored lists is gonna be every three
weeks rather than every one and he's
hoping that
that means that people will have a bit
more confidence in in making their
holiday choices
but this is the headline that he didn't
want and this is the
thousands of uk holidaymakers who were
in here in mexico basically
as they were flying to mexico it the the
the country got put on the red list so
they then have basically a massive
scramble
uh to try and get back to avoid this
extremely costly and difficult
quarantine
and we've seen some of the conditions in
these quarantine hotels and they're not
really somewhere you want to be
and paying thousands and thousands of
pounds for it so as you can imagine i
think the metro's got quotes from a
couple on their rearranged honeymoon
absolutely devastating for them to find
out basically upon landing
that they are then gonna they've got two
days to get home before to to avoid this
and lose out on their holiday so
it's more chaos and i have to say that
the travel
program from the government this summer
has been totally chaotic i
i admire anyone who is daring to venture
on a foreign holiday um i'll be
i'll be keeping well in there i think
i'm going to angle see that's my plan
good for you um i have to admit i've
just cancelled my holiday as just all
too much like hard work um the
metro talks about that increased cost of
um the the red zone and hotel quarantine
a family of four with two teens is to
leap 78
from 3 700 to
and seventy 6575. grand shap saying that
um it's not been meeting the costs
they were millions short which is why
the prices have have gone up
um but many uh travel agents uh tour
operators airlines
etc saying you know it's been so ruined
it's too late and people are too nervous
to to travel
and it in a sense it's a sector that
that has just been clobbered and
continues to be club but this is such
an important season isn't it carol for
for the travel industry
you know i got an email today from um
a man who runs a a travel dependent
business and it was one of the saddest
things
that i've ever read and he just said
today you know you know
he's written he's written a letter he's
written an email to graham chaps and he
says you know
it's people like him who bear the
fallout
of these ridiculous you know choppy
changy government decisions
he says you know his savings is gone
he's about to lose his home
he's about to lose his business and he's
saying all it needs to be done
is that people need to be doubled out
and tested before they come back into
the country
and he's right you know and this is one
of the saddest emails that i've ever
read
because it is people like him who are
dealing with the fallout and every time
boris and people like graham chapstick
one of these flip-flop turn around
they wreck people's lives i mean liam
mentioned that that honeymoon couple
you know they were going for two weeks
god knows how long they saved up and
many thousands of pounds
and they they're going to land they're
going to spend the day their land
packing
to come back the next day and it's going
to cost them a fortune because now
single seats back from mexico you know
this is ripoff if they're costing 7 000
pounds it's ludicrous and if they don't
pay that seven thousand bags to get back
you just mentioned the cost of those
hotels you know two and a half
you know two thousand eight hundred for
one person and then
fourteen fifteen hundred quid for a
teenager to stay in these hotels which
are not great places and you know
schatz was asked today and because he
was talking about how this new
three-week turnaround thing he's going
to have where they re-examine their the
um the conditions
every three weeks he says this is gonna
mean that people aren't going to be
looking over the shoulders yes they are
because he couldn't guarantee that it
wouldn't be every three weeks he said if
conditions change
it'll be every two weeks or every one
week so people don't know
what the hell they're supposed to be
doing now it's a mess
it i mean it's not all bad news travel
firms are saying they've seen a huge
surge in demand for example
train operator eurostar uh said bookings
on its london to paris route
doubled after uh the confirmation that
france would get off its special
uh amber plus uh listing uh online
travel agency sky scanner recorded a 45
increase airline emirates said it
received a huge surge in queries so
and so it goes on um just yeah
you mentioned those companies those
companies have doubled the price of
their tickets today in anticipation
of what's going to happen on sunday you
know people are getting ripped off all
the time it's great for eurostar they're
going to make a fortune
because of these flip flops but you know
this is not good for people who've saved
up all year for a holiday
yeah the changes to the travel rules
come into effect at 4 a.m on sunday
which is effectively overnight on
saturday i never understand given most
holiday companies run saturday sunday
where they don't just make it overnight
on sunday so you get
at least sunday's travel home anyway i'm
just going to draw your attention to a
story uh on the bottom of the front page
of the telegraph
which is that mps are suggesting that
travel tests are a rip-off
as it emerged holiday makers are paying
the equivalent
of 100 000 pounds for each test that is
actually sequenced these are the pcr
tests
and the great you know debate about them
is that they allow
genetic sequencing to find variants but
um
the story of course is that only 5 or 1
in 20 actually
get sequenced um so liam just just as we
leave the travel section suggestion you
should have a lateral flow test and if
that's positive then you get pcr tested
and then that can be sequenced is that
when the pressure is going to carry on
on this isn't it really
yeah and it's an interesting one because
we know that the lateral flow tests are
not
as as accurate and for example me and my
partner recently had
covered both of us and and several
several lateral flow tests through the
week before we protect the positive and
then obviously you go for pcr
the questions around it are how accurate
it is
and whether you are sort of infectious
at that time whereas the pcr is
obviously better at picking up
but you know obviously these are these
are huge costs and uh
for people who are already forking out a
lot to go on holiday to pay and it's
again just one just one more thing that
is going to obviously put people off
wanting to travel
yeah i hope you're both okay you all
right
uh yes
you're fine okay good to hear and you
carol obviously good dear too
um let's go to the eye shall we uh 16
and 17 year olds uh confirmation
yesterday that they will have access to
the jab it's how to get to them now and
how to get the message across
she's coughing now she's talking
um it's you know and and the idea is
it's gonna be on buses you know messages
in nightclubs even and so on but it's
it's an important age range i suppose
carol isn't it to get jabbed
well it's a very important age range
considering that
the people in hospital now are young
people there's a thousand
young critically ill and hospital as we
speak
um and you know but there's a part of me
gets
you know a bit across the idea that
young people are having to be
bribed with cinema tickets and kebabs
and
pizzas and and they're going to be
bosses going around
you know making it easy for them to get
a job why aren't they getting a job you
know this
it's a social responsibility now that's
got to come
before their personal choice now and i
just
it makes me a little bit crossed that
young people aren't
taking up the vaccine in the way they
should in light of the fact
that the majority of people in hospital
are young and
70 of those who are in the hospital
haven't had the job i mean it's pretty
self-explanatory
get the jab you know never mind what
your your morals or your principles are
get a job inside you know because
it's not just going to be safe for you
you're going to safeguard everyone
around you
and you know you're going to you're
going to look after the nhs whatever
happened to that message you know let's
let's not power pressure on the nhs
that's exactly what's happening there
because
of people who are refusing to be
vaccinated and young people who just
can't be bothered to get it
yes and some um some questions about how
many young people
will get the jab um figures not racing
ahead as they did for the over 80s or
the over 70s or
you know those older age ranges um but
um
so many young people have had covid and
are being told
to wait a bit uh in order to get the
vaccination
after they've had it to recover a bit
more that could explain some of the
delays so it could be that this is
this is temporary liam yeah well
and so i was up to you to get my second
job when i became ill
um and i was desperate to get it but i
couldn't because i just fallen ill so i
then had to wait
i've still not had it now i've got to
wait 28 days so that is a potential
delay because obviously when things
reopen particularly on the 19th of july
it was young people who immediately were
mixing in nightclubs so there will have
been quite a lot of people getting it
then who will then have to wait
so hopefully we'll we will as that time
progresses we will see
more and more young people getting it i
think one thing that's interesting here
is the government and and the nhs
wanting to bring in the likes of
social media influencers because we
actually know that that has been a
problem
where there's so much disinformation
being put out on social media we've seen
investigations about
where some of that is coming from from
russia and other places i i know of
young people who have been wrongly
influenced
by this disinformation so if obviously
they can get some of these extremely
powerful
um social media influencers with
millions and millions of followers if
you can get them on board putting out
the right message that this vaccine is
safe
that everybody should get it but it will
protect you and your family i think that
could be a really important step
okay um carol let's move to the daily
mail um
they've gone off to alex sharma the
climate minister they say he jetted to
30 nations in the last seven months
six of them on on the red list he said
days after returning from red list
bangladesh
the cabinet minister met prince charles
indoors without a mask
then visited a primary school um we
obviously have not verified this this is
what they have uh found out
uh nonetheless i guess it is his job
ahead of cop 26
to meet and greet and talk to you and
persuade and cajole as many people as
possible
um what's your view well that's what he
will say
of course and he will say that he has to
go and meet all these people but you
know the rest of the world
has been on zoom for the past year and a
half uh you know we've been talking to
each other all over the world on zoom
and it just seems incredible to me why
alex sharma couldn't do the same thing
it's quite a nice thing to go to 30
countries in seven months if you can
and have a page one by somebody else and
go and stay go
to conferences and stay in nice hotels
it's a great thing to do but actually
you know when you're telling the rest of
the country to stay indoors to do your
business
you know where you can from home via
zoom
well then it's a little bit much for him
to be going to do that and you know
the fact that he the fact that he wasn't
quarantined or had to go into isolation
when he came back
if he didn't have to do that presumably
when he came back he got a test
which then released him well why can't
the rest of us do that why are the rest
of us
being held in in hotels for 10 days at
massive cost
it's the climate change minister can
have a test and then move freely among
whoever he wants to move with
that is the height of the policy he will
explain away
his reasons for having to go abroad but
she can't explain away that the fact he
didn't have to isolate me came back
carol we're not we're not in charge of a
major global conference i suppose that's
one reason why
uh the rule might be different but we'll
have to talk about that more a little
bit later on plenty more still to come
uh is it fair for universities to set
their own entrance exams
because the pandemic has influenced
a-level grades back without just a
moment
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me now carol malone and liam thorpe
welcome back to both of you oh she's
gone where's she gone
she can't do that to me anyway liam
let's talk
let's talk to you oh here she is
only carol malone going to talk to liam
oh it's too late popper i'll tell you um
carol i'll start with you then daily
telegraph um
i suppose not surprisingly given what
happened to a levels last year
universities are having a bit of trouble
sifting through who's good and who's not
um with the expectation that grades will
be inflated
yes um so this will likely
i'm not being disrespectful i'm coughing
okay so universities are saying they're
going to go back to entrance exams
and because they could they can't any
longer rely
on aids what i'm saying is there is
i think i think we might have to um dial
you back in carol
powder or not i'm sticking with liam um
liam take up the story if you can
yeah so i mean with exams being
cancelled for the second year in a row
we kind of know that when the results
come next week there's going to be some
problems
of course last year the problems were
different there was a lot of
young people who felt that they were
being very unfairly treated
having grades marked down sometimes
based on the historical performance of
schools this time with it being solid
and teacher grades the expectation is
that there's going to be large-scale
grade inflation
and what telegraph is saying is as they
understand us at universities
who are basically struggling because too
many people
too many prospective students are
essentially making the grade
and that courses will be oversubscribed
but they're going to look um the idea of
university specific entrance exam what
the guardian
are saying um tonight is that the
government is basically being forced to
fund hundreds of extra university places
and medical and dental courses
because this rampant graduation means
that there aren't going to be enough
places as there are so
i think we are in for a pretty chaotic
week next week and
with the greatest of respect i'm not
sure i've got that much faith in gavin
williamson handling it all
yes and indeed uh in terms of the
guardian story extra cash for medical
schools
um i remember speaking to the body that
represents medical
colleges and they suggested that they
over offer
30 to 35 percent of places because they
think people
won't do as well in their a levels so uh
you know not surprising that we've
reached this point
and we're also going to talk about bruce
johnson margaret thatcher and coal mines
but we'll have to leave that liam for
now carol in her absence too
thank you both very much indeed